on a fait une belle campagne une
campagne positive auprès des gens j'ai
revu beaucoup de gens qui m'ont dit que
vesoul avancé que c'était fier de vesoul
on a fait une campagne sur trois
thématiques vesoul humaine vesoul
attractive et vesoul naturel des
thématiques qui sont retrouvés retrouve
dans ce petit fascicule que nous avons
distribué partout dans les boîtes aux
lettres
eh bien on va continuer à faire avancer
vesoul en étant positifs et ambitieux
pour le vesoul de l'avenir très bien
jean yannick tu penses et à vous alors
vous vous appartient c'est l'avenir
l'économie
le zénith le foyer-logement l'hôpital
nous on sera tout faire moi je sors du
privé et j'ai des façons de travailler
autre que et ce sera pour le meilleur
pour vesoul
merci frédéric bernabé 30 secondes pour
vous je suis très fier d'être à tête de
la liste unie pour gagner qui est
solidaire et écologique
nous avons une équipe soudée c'est très
importante compétente pour un projet
solide dont j'ai donné quelques éléments
et qui donne et qui vont donner de
l'espoir aux vésuliens et au vésulienne
ce qui nous rend pleinement confiance
pour dimanche 15 mars
marie dominique aubry c'est à vous pour
finir ce tour de table ce projet que je
vous propose
et bien c'est avec vous je les construis
élaboré c'est grâce à vous que nous
avons cette vision pour vesoul et cette
ambition
alors ce projet ils vous ressemblent et
avec l'ensemble de mon équipe nous
aurons à coeur devrait quotidiennement
pour redynamiser vesoul renforcer le
pouvoir d'achat et la sécurité des
vésuliens alors dimanche en votant pour
moi vous voterez pour un maire à temps
plein pour les six prochaines années
pour une ville construite ensemble
autrement